i've heard the 40s are
magic yeah oh and grandma kept on
telling me 40 is the best sex and i was
like okay i'm ready good for a grandma
and so far
kim kardashian is filling all the
details on her romance with pete
davidson you guys have stalked me long
enough
i'll finally answer you so this is how
it went down with pete on who lose the
kardashians kim reveals how her
relationship with pete came to be
following their sketch they did together
on saturday night live now are you gonna
kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
when we kissed in scene
it was just a vibe and i was like oh
[ __ ] maybe
maybe i just need to try something
different yeah but kim says pete didn't
make it easy after the sparks flew pete
does not come to my after party everyone
was at my after party does not give me
the time of day and turns out it was kim
who eventually made the first move you
just gotta roll with it explaining that
she contacted an snl producer to get
pete's number i text him i wasn't even
thinking like oh my god i'm going to be
in a relationship with him i was just
thinking like
i've heard about this bde need to get
out there like i need to just like
jump start
i was just basically dtf but kim's dtf
attitude blossomed into a full-blown
romance it's really lit and fun and
crazy and now she can't help but gush
about her man pete is has got to be
literally the best human being i've ever
met like the best heart people always
say like oh he's so funny and it's like
has to do with how funny he is that's
like
fourth on my list of why i like him i
would say the perfect word to describe
pete is genuine i mean i think just that
i never knew you can just be so happy
watching tv series and going to the gym
it's a sentiment kim echoed to e.t ahead
of the show's premiere what do you love
about him what's your favorite thing
about him he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
[Laughter]
and get this there's an unexpected megan
fox connection to kim's love story of
course the actress is engaged to one of
pete's best friend's machine gun kelly
after we got together and it was like a
thing megan fox texts me and is like is
this for real because
he asked me for your number months ago
and like i was like dude you have a
better shot
of like
me and
mgk getting eaten by crocodiles than you
ever getting her number like never gonna
happen do not ask us wild how these
things eventually work themselves out
right i mean it's so exciting and now
over six months into their relationship
it seems like things are going well for
the couple including in the intimacy
department i've heard the 40s are
magic yeah can't wait to be in my four
days
no seriously when i turned 40 everyone
said it's the best sex of your life
oh and grandma kept on telling me 40 is
the best sex and i was like okay i'm
ready good for a grandma
and so far
and those around kim are loving the
impact pete's having on her i definitely
noticed that kim is happier i think that
she's so much nicer now thank you pete
i'm so into this new kim yeah the whole
family is all for kim and pete's
relationship what do you all love about
pete what are your favorite things about
him i love that he's kind and really
really thoughtful he's the most
thoughtful person
and i love
yeah and i love the chemistry that kim
and him have together it's really sweet
i thought you said the chemistry it's
like okay chemistry chemistry
[Music]